c'est moche quand l élite en claque
honnêtement je pensais qu'elle avait été
très loin avec le suppléant de dire que
penser quand elle les a vus ensemble les
deux qu'ils étaient faits l'un pour
l'autre les traits fois j'ai bien envie
d'appeler fatima j'ai encore joué c'est
vrai vous avez été surpris l'as fan de
bonheur est dans le pré m6 ça vous
détruit
ça m'a pas tant surpris que ça en
revanche j'ai été ravi de son ca des
mamans du départ oui c'est benjamin
castadi tout va bien jamais on est on
est quelques-uns autour de la table on
est on est sûr aussi lu vendredi ont
fermé vendredi
vous n'avez pas voulu nous dire ce qui
s'était réellement passé et là on
regarde et me charrière patatras vous
avez quitté ma vie quitté didier et le
programme what the fuck
qu'est ce qui s'est passé qu'est-ce qui
est le plus bas très bas oui quand
isabelle arrivée bébé tu veux qu'il
avait changé d'attitude 1ers mois et ses
divers mais plus verte ailleurs et qu
elle que sa lettre en procédés qui a eu
lieu à non plus mais aimer comment vous
avez vécu parce que quand vous tombez
des images de vos églises c'était quand
même très très sympa si vous voulez le
marié même et qu'il a changé alors en
gros parce que si c'est pourquoi on
s'est parlé on vous a procès à vous de
jouer la comédie mais finalement c'est
j'ai le sentiment que c'est didier qui
vous a pris un peu pour une
[Musique]
je cherchais quelqu'un de salta de
sérieux et je n'ai pour prendre et
créera un vilain prebon est saturé n'y
ait pas d'accord vous parlez de qui des
deux ans a eu de quoi de démission ah
oui ah oui est ce que est ce que vous
regrettez d'avoir anticipé ou à la
mauvaise entrée et si vous aviez une
chose à dire 10 ce serait quoi
aujourd'hui que qui joue un double jeu
de camaret donc vous avez besoin en fait
c'est lui qui vous a trompé et dès
qu'ils avaient des goûts ça change et
puis maintenant un vrai que j'allais
m'approcher avec elle aussi comme
d'habitude donc vous pensez que des
émules et est plus attiré par l'autre
prétendante que par vous de l'intention
c'est quand même deux prêts talent c'est
vrai que ça j'ai l'impression que vous
avez tout dit que vous avez été que vous
êtes b c ou d une femme blessée en fait
ça ce soir vous avez un tournant
véhicule oui ou non vous et vous baissez
vous avez vous avez renoncé en fait
demandé le monde bonjour quand même
aujourd'hui est ce que est ce que ça va
mieux après le passage dans l'émission
est ce que puisque les commentaires se
sont un peu calmées après après-midi
[Musique]
dans l'église nous nous on a beaucoup ri
et nous entraider est ce que vous pensez
qu'il ya que des barres de facilement là
vers lui la star du programme prix
c'est pour ça qu'elle à cause aussi de
la chute de 500000 l'épisode hier il est
calamiteux tous les mecs nos années
didier taylor dans leur coin il y aura
plein qui agissent ils se laissent faire
parler situe à celles vivant là bas
qu'il y faisait mais elle je fais ça ils
subissent tous y en a marre de ces
gars-là c'est vrai que loisir avec elles
n'ont pas tous eu raison de ce bar voilà
merci beaucoup pâti non il fait perdre
10 ou vous souhaite plein de bonnes
choses pour la suite et j'espère qu'il y
aura moins de que les gens on bouge on
vous au comprise et que voilà tout ce
qui avait été dit voilà on vous embrasse
fort vadim à vous abonner
[Applaudissements]